in the lobby of Ramsey solutions la and
Vanessa are with us hey guys how are ya
hi David great yeah great good to have
you guys where do you live
San Antonio Texas welcome to Nashville
okay pronounce your first name is Aloise
all right hello yes I said it correctly
okay good perfect well welcome to
Nashville here to do your debt-free
screen I love it and how much have you
paid off
two hundred and seven thousand whoa and
how long did that take seven years Wow
and your range of household income
during that time that is an incredible
question Dave we started about 30,000
when we got married and slowly our
income increased we got to the point
we're making about a hundred and five
and then I mean life hit us in the face
we got down to zero hmm in this process
so it's been quite the journey all over
the place what do you guys do for a
living now I'm a teacher mm-hmm and I
work in human resources but I'm
venturing into new business development
great good for you guys
so I'm guessing as long as this took and
the size of the number this must be your
home let me tell you we have a pH D and
D um B and D EBT we've made all the
mistakes so it's not your home it's not
we actually have been renting the whole
time because you say not to have that
house when you have debt so one baby
step three be saving up for a home now
good for you what kind of debt was this
well both of our cars uh-huh
both of our student loans a lot of
medical bills we had some hardships
along the way and so we had a lot of
medical bills the credit cards you name
it we had it yeah wow you guys were
normal
oh you're normally broke normal with a
few zeroes yeah Wow Wow so what started
you on this journey seven years ago my
mom took me to one of your live events
in San Antonio mm-hmm and I ran out of
there on fire and then I ran into a
little bit of water spell a spell Eloy
oh my god
but you know we took FPU and around 2009
and that changed everything for us at
that time we didn't know what was in
store for us and I feel strongly that
God was laying that foundation for us he
knew what was about to happen and we
were prepared and you gave us the tools
that we needed to face the hardships
that we faced and we had job loss I got
run over by a car whoa yes we had
everything happen and that's how our
income dropped to zero there were so
many instances when we weren't working
but we just continued on yeah whoa they
just flashed up a picture for the TV of
you in the hospital yeah so like a
pedestrian you just got you got hammered
I mean I ran over myself oh that's even
worse it is I parked on an incline
rolled over me it was worried but doing
better now two years later Wow ouch yeah
yeah oh my goodness we've been through
it Dave and I'll tell you if you don't
mind here well Vanessa was in the
hospital I'd lost my job
three days before Oh No so we have
nothing coming in and no plan other than
the tools we gained through this class
you know it changed our lives forever
yes our family rallied around us but our
church group are married for life group
at the church they just really kept us
in the lane yes and had it not been for
all those people and all that help we
just would not have been able to get
through it we had a really supportive
family amazing one more church do you go
to we go to Community Bible Church in
San Antonio EBC give him a good shout
out there was a good where that good to
you in your life that's always good to
it as church should be yeah absolutely
good yes very proud of you gosh thank
you so you have been through it man in
seven years I don't know if I've had him
by owner he'd been run over by a car I
mean I've heard I've used the metaphor
I've never really said got run you know
really physically literally got run over
by cars
Wow unbelievable yeah so what was the
moment like after all of that when you
pay that very last debt which debt was
it was the last one Dave I'll tell you
um it was our student loan yeah yeah it
was our student loans but right before
we're two months away from paying off
our student I'm sorry paying off our
last
two months prior Texas has the worst
hailstorm they've ever had and so our
cars got totaled in that process oh my
god
hey yeah we have a gonna do it and and
so I was thinking to myself yeah we can
see the finish line but we're just not
going to get that cross it obviously
it's not in the cards and Vanessa says
well you know what we can do is buy the
cars back like Dave always says we
should do and then use that money to
propel us forward and so we're driving
around some beat-up cars they're
literally been beat up they work but
they work and and that money is what
propelled us to pay off our final
student loan debt and and then cleared
out and it felt amazing well that last
day when you pay off that last one it
was so surreal we almost couldn't
believe it I was almost afraid to walk
outside and fear that something might
happen okay Ted side there's hail storms
and cars out there I'm not going out
there
mercy bless your heart
Wow Wow so I you know there's families
out there that have fought and struggled
and scratched and clawed through this
process all these years and there's some
of them listening right now the 12
million on I mean you guys didn't just
get out of that you persevered yeah and
you you've gone through you know been
hot and cold been water been fire and
then job loss and medical and everything
else and then the two cars get totaled
yeah Lee talked to that couple that's
that they're just getting hammered right
now and they don't think they're gonna
they're about to quit why didn't you
quit you know growing up we both
experienced a lot of adversity in our
childhoods and avoid said it best
earlier he said you know we're fighters
Vanessa we fight through everything and
so I would encourage them to just have
faith have faith in God and know that
you take one step at a time the best way
to eat an elephant one piece at a time
and so one day after another day after
another day you just keep trucking along
and eventually you'll get there and I
think it's important to know that to
give yourself the grace when you fall
off to get back on you know we're not
perfect by any means we've made all the
mistakes in the book and so it's
important that people extend the grace
to themselves that they need to know
that you know what you fall back off
just get back on and you can do it you
can do anything if you're intentional
about it and you take the steps
necessary to get there you know Dave
when we decided that we were going to do
this we never took our eyes off the
prize never never and no matter how hard
life hit us we just got back together
because we committed that we were gonna
see this through and we just kept
pushing forward regardless of the
circumstances in that and I'm you know I
let everybody who's going through this
who's experiencing it who thinks that
they cannot do it keep your eyes on that
prize and regardless of what comes your
way no matter how hard life hits you
just keep pushing through it that's
what's gonna get you through yep this
definitely strengthened our marriage and
this is my free spirit right here I love
him to death but you know it took a lot
for me to understand his mentality at
the beginning he didn't want to get on
at first it took us a few years to kind
of both get on board and I had to
understand that he's not me and my
intensity isn't going to be his
intensity but as long as together we can
get there we can do it and so it
definitely strengthened our marriage a
lot okay thank you man but you guys are
a picture of perseverance seven years
yeah well after all of that was it worth
it oh so I'm sorry it I'm so worth it
absolutely Wow now you don't have any
painless none and you make $105,000 yes
I mean is that that page I mean that
budget must look different now oh yeah
we learn to live off one income a few
years into it and we realized that we
had more money than we thought and so we
cut back as much as we could and we just
live off one paycheck even today and so
I think that's one of also the dangers
is when you realize that you can cash
flow a lot that gets a little dangerous
because then you realize oh I have all
this cash I could do this I could do
this and so it's opportunity cost at
what expense and we had to learn along
the way that just because we have the
money doesn't mean that we should
necessarily do it because if we do more
things that we shouldn't be doing it's
gonna take us longer to pay off debt
yeah man you guys are on fire I love you
yeah oh to hear you say proud of you
your your apps your absolute heroes this
is amazing okay very well done well we
got a copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired book for you that's the next
chapter build wealth and be outrageously
generous and you're well on your way to
doing that you'll be doing that the rest
of your life
alright alloy and Vanessa from San
Antonio Texas two hundred and seven
thousand dollars paid off in seven years
making thirty two 105 to zero to 105
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one they are awesome
man
Wow oh you can do it your turn next
you ready set go hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you